have you ever instructed a group before
and in any way have you ever taught have
you ever led a group and throughout your
life well thank you for asking
it's kind of my job I was a camp
counselor have you ever been to camp
count I was a camp counselor yeah yeah
wait tell me about it
what is this all about me before come on
I wore a lot of sunblock I'll tell you
that much right now did you like it I
did I thought was okay with it I had a
tough I think I had fourth graders that
was a tough time but isn't there like
this unbelievable reward and like a
group of kids just automatically adoring
you I didn't get that this was you know
I think this was like 1980 this is when
and my shorts were probably too short
and my legs were too skinny and I don't
think they absolutely adored me some of
them thought I was funny but they didn't
absolutely drama teachers adore you did
they love you well I was wearing
headgear I don't know if they it felt
like they adored me right um but I got I
was like it was like a tidal wave of
that wonderful adoration Andy yes did
you have that I never was never a camp
counselor no oh no I I avoided children
until I they let there be a camp
counselor when you pull like that
I get it like a roof or the forearms
yeah apparently yeah yeah no I I never
was it did you get along with the kids
were you good with kid I was so good
with the good kids
I wasn't wait a minute
that doesn't count so if there was a kid
that was bad you you had a hard time I
wasn't great I mean I didn't know how to
I didn't know how to like discipline or
behave around kids that that weren't
great mm-hmm
so there was a kid that a man this is an
embarrassing story to talk that's the
kind we like all right I won't go I'll
venture forward so so late at night
this little kid was she kept making
farting noises and well let's hold on a
second yeah was she actually having an
intestinal distress or was she making
the noises to be a wise guy
wise guy yeah yeah yeah and anyway so
she was doing that for a little bit and
I was pretending to be asleep and she
said to the other kids she was like ah
she's asleep and I was in my sleeping
bag and I was like get that Mouse yeah
and she kept doing it you had told her
not to do it yeah and so I looked up
like a little leopard mm-hmm right up
onto her top monk and I grabbed her by
the collar and I said you don't
sending you home right now tonight in
the middle of the night and it's like
2:00 a.m. and and she started to cry and
I felt good
don't you you know you know I've never
done that but you feel the same
no never wasn't talking about I wasn't
getting paid for the collar
you guys know they're all calling the
police right now
[Laughter]
you